some members of the British royal family
are opening up in a way rarely heard in
the halls of Buckingham Palace Prince
William and Prince Harry are talking for
the first time about their own mental
health struggles following the sudden
death of their mother Princess Diana
nearly twenty years ago mark Phillips
has the story it's Friday the 21st of
April it's 4:00 p.m. and this is a very
special official charm at last a Duke
and Duchess may have found their true
calling
last week Harry Styles went straight to
number one with his debut single
fine off the tines can he do it again
William and Kate as DJ's promoting their
mental health charities but clearly
taking to their new roles on radio woman
well ed sheeran retain that top spot he
had 13 weeks at number one with shape of
you before he came along supported
Easter Prince Harry it turns out is part
of the mental health charity pitch as
well joining his brother and
sister-in-law in a discussion of the
risks of bottling emotions up this is
what the two sons of Princess Diana's
say they did to repress the pain they
endured four years after her death we've
never really talked about it we've never
really talked about losing your mom at
such a young age and when you speak to
other people's families and little kids
and stuff you think well you know I
don't want them to have to go through
the same things even her and I over the
years and not talked enough about it
you know mother they're talking now so
everyone can hear equates it to like a
boiling pan of super white of the lid on
we just perfected just taking the lid
off yeah the Royals were once the
epitome is the British stiff upper lip
not anymore
for CBS this morning Saturday I mark
Phillips